(happy music plays)
(whooshing)
- I'm Dr. John Sessa, I'm
the executive director
of the Vanderpump Dog Foundation.
And we are here at our brand new shelter
in West Hollywood.
Really the whole idea of this shelter
is to re image the shelter
and re image a shelter dog.
So we bring in dogs from kill shelters
that don't necessarily look their best.
They were neglected, they have a lot
of rehabilitation and PTSD issues.
Immediately when the dogs come in,
after they're quarantined and
we do our health assessment,
we get them Vanderpuffed.
And so that allows them
to have a new image
and we've noticed that
it really does improve
the way that they walk around.
They feel a lot better.
So now we're gonna get two
of our newest rescues Vanderpuffed.
So let's go meet 'em.
- My name is Hannah, I'm
the adoption coordinator
here at Vanderpump Dogs,
and this is Buster.
Buster was from a high kill shelter.
On his card it said that
he was an owner surrender,
that means that his owner
didn't want him anymore
or couldn't take care of him anymore.
If he was not rescued, he
probably would've been euthanized.
He's pretty dirty but we're gonna take him
and get him all cleaned up
and ready to be adopted.
- This is someone very
special. This is Dewey.
One of our rescuers who
goes to the shelters for us
actually saw Dewey get
thrown from a vehicle.
Dewey was obviously in a
very neglected situation
so his coat is matted,
he has fleas and ticks,
he's very dirty, and
he's gonna get a makeover
and surly he's nervous now,
but he's gonna get used to his new home
and eventually get a permanent home.
So let's go get them Vanderpuffed.
- So typically when we get these guys in,
we do a full assessment on their coats,
and their ears, and their teeth
and just to see what the
condition of the dog is in.
We give 'em a bath, and clipping,
and conditioner, and a blow dry,
and they look as good as new.
Right buddy?
(happy music plays)
(whooshing)
- So now that we've put
on the finishing touch,
we're gonna go and make sure
that these guys are spayed and neutered
so that they're ready to
go to their forever home.
- Thanks for hangin'
out with us today guys.
(happy music plays).
Bye.
(whooshing)
(creaking)